so we are about halfway through our
first semester of experimenting with
Coursera we have four faculty members
Diana kleiner Paul bloom Bob Shiller and
key Lamar who were really are leaders in
this to be able to say that they were
wanted to be the first four to teach
their courses on this platform we're so
grateful to the four of them for for
doing this we're about halfway through
so as we say up here it's way too early
to make definitive judgments about
Coursera but that doesn't mean it's too
early to start you know developing some
impressions and sharing some impressions
I think I'm a little bit inspired by all
the conversation about the changes in
the late night television hosts so I've
structured this is a top 10 list so
we'll go through it but I'm going to
change the format a little bit and I
don't think the media my media
colleagues will like this but if you
have questions during the presentation
let's just stop and we can ask we don't
have to wait until the end because this
sort of jumps from topic to topic I
should also say that as we go through
these a lot of these items that will
talk about are not new ideas and they
may actually be ideas that we've already
discussed beforehand due to information
that we received from some colleagues or
from some peers I should say who were
experimenting on one of the MOOC
platforms but now we have first-hand
knowledge of it so we can talk a little
bit more intimately about each of these
points so this first one is certainly
one of the obvious ones that to mount a
course on any of the MOOC platforms is a
lot of work and it's a lot of work for a
lot of people first and foremost the
lead faculty member obviously but then
we think about the team that supports
that lead faculty member there or you
know teaching assistants which we'll
talk about in a moment the broadcasting
media team Ryan Sarah and Kirsten who
were in the back is sort of the course
operations team it takes a legal help it
takes coordinating with the office of
public affairs and communications as
well as aya to get the messaging out
there so it really is a team of people
needed to mount one of these courses and
it's a lot of work especially the first
time around so what we're hoping is that
if any of the faculty members are
willing to offer the course a second or
third time that we will see a little
it'll s work the second or third time
because we'll have videos created will
have the core structures in place but
the first time we have to be clear it is
a lot of work for everyone involved
secondly this is what we're talking
about with teaching assistants I didn't
use the term just because we're not
exactly sure about title so we'll just
focus on what it is the graduate
students who are helping us in these
courses the lead faculty member needs
very strong teaching and academic
support on the other ends things like
technical or administration we are
helping the faculty member from that
respect but each faculty member has a
teaching fellow to help them think about
core structure to help them manage the
message boards and help them engage in
the course I think what's interesting
about this is as Sarah said you know the
best way to give experiences to or to
gain experience is to give experience
and perhaps these MOOCs offer us new
ways to provide graduate students just
small slivers of experience in online
teaching now one of our faculty members
made a great point last week when we
were talking about this idea of teaching
support he said what I find is someone
who would make a great teaching
assistant in the classroom is likely to
make a great teaching assistant online
but if you think about that a little bit
more I think there's one other aspect to
this and that there are other
opportunities for that teaching
assistant to think about technology so
how do you really manage a discussion
forum how do you pose a question to get
a conversation unfolding over a message
thread and these are the types of things
that we can experiment with on Coursera
with the four courses that we have will
go back to legal for a second again this
ties into the first idea of the the
really group of people that it takes to
support these courses when it comes to
using copyrighted materials in your
classroom and what we're really thinking
about here are readings if you want to
provide your class you know whether
their articles are parts of books it
takes time money or luck and usually all
three and this is something we need to
plan certainly for the next time around
as we talk with the faculty members if
they do have readings that they'd like
to supply their students what is the
model there to work with the publishing
company work with the rights holders to
be able to share that content in the
context of a MOOC classroom because as
you can imagine from a
publisher this is a very different
request to say we have a course with
150,000 students enroll and we'd like to
use your book is that okay and they're
not entirely sure what the relationship
is there so we need to think about that
and certainly work through it hand in
hand with the with the publishers and
the rights holders when we talk about
the students now we shift over to the
student the students want an active
experience on Coursera this is certainly
one of the big shifts between the MOOCs
of 2014 and the first generation of open
courses whether that was MIT
OpenCourseWare are open Yale courses
those were all very passive experience
as it was a matter of going to a website
downloading material or watching
material and sort of learning on your
own the MOOC platforms of today are
interactive there's assessment involved
there's discussion that's needed and
that's what these students are looking
for but the fortunate side of this is
that there are many ways to meet this
expectation and I think this ties in
very nicely with the opportunities for
graduate students so when we look at our
four courses that are currently on
Coursera they're very different they're
very different in subject matter they're
very different in the way the faculty
members are engaging in the course so
I'll use a kiehl's course for example
one of the things we did was work with
his faculty members to invite them down
to the broadcast studio on a Friday
afternoon and for one hour they were in
virtually a message board and they
responded to questions in real time so
students watch the lectures and post
questions they were firing off answers
as quickly as they could at the end of
an hour we had three Teaching Fellows
with very tired hands and about 2,000
students who are very appreciative of
the time that these Teaching Fellows
took to answer their questions but they
gained some great experience in this so
it really is a win-win situation Paul
bloom does a weekly video show where he
and his teaching assistant pull some of
the more comments of the comments I
catch his eye throughout the weekend the
message board and they run through them
and they provide their perspective on
video and the two of them co-hosts that
so they're his teaching fellows getting
a really interesting opportunity to talk
with Paul about these concepts and give
her thoughts and opinions on the matter
so they're very different ways to do
this a lot of opportunity the other
thing about Coursera students is
are very they're opinionated and they
are really loyal and excited about this
opportunity which is a phenomenal thing
so as a faculty member as an instructor
you need to be prepared for a lot of
different opinions and some of them are
perhaps not so complimentary because
students have different expectations but
again I don't think this is very
different from a regular classroom as we
talk about this experience with our four
faculty members they say well really in
anything you should take the top five
percent and the bottom five percent
throw those out and focus on the middle
and you need to remember that in a MOOC
sometimes it could get a little bit
overwhelming because we're now talking
about tens of thousands of students who
are watching your lectures and
commenting on the message boards but
really need to keep that in mind is not
respond to every individual criticism or
thought because students just have
different expectations this was
something that we heard about but now is
one of these ideas that we can validate
this idea that Coursera students help
each other in a significant way the
number that we were told by the Coursera
leadership team early on was that the
average response time was 22 minutes so
after a question by a student was posed
they felt that they received a really an
answer that solved their issue with in
22 minutes by another student and we've
seen this firsthand the conversations
that unfold student to student the help
that they want to provide one another is
just is fascinating and it's helpful for
us because as you can imagine with four
courses and tens of thousands of
students and students who are all around
the world learning 24 hours a day we
couldn't possibly keep up with all the
questions so to have the students there
helping each other is not only
heartening but it's really helpful as
well which leads us into another point
about the student message boards like
any message board if you on the internet
there's not a message board on the
internet that does not include what we
would call trolls or some type of
nonsense people just looking to agitate
the conversation but the course error
message threads also include plenty of
unbelievable intelligent and exciting
conversation I'm just going to give one
quick example here from Bob Schiller's
course so Bob's teaching financial
markets on Coursera
his you know lectures are there you know
they're not easy I mean these are Yale
courses you know he is a Nobel Prize
winner there's a lot of material that
you need to know to really understand
what he's talking about so here's one
student in Bob's course who is taking it
upon themselves to go and watch each
lecture and then provide their own notes
to the lecture and background material
to help the other students understand
some of the points that Bob is making in
the lecture there are charts and graphs
Sarah who from my team who is managing
this course with Bob showed him on
Friday and bob was intrigued enough and
looked at it and thought it was quality
enough where we're going to contact the
student and ask if you'd like to become
a teaching fellow what you call a
community ta on Coursera to help and
perhaps provide lecture notes from this
point forward and this is just one
example of recent example that we became
aware of on Thursday in all of our other
classes you just see such amazing
conversation unfold and what's really
phenomenal about it is the variety of
students demographics age ranges regions
and that really you know as we've heard
this opportunity of using technology to
connect cultures to connect parts of the
world we see that here as well this was
of course one of the big criticisms
about MOOCs and has been a point of
discussion for a long time this idea of
retention rates here I say there are
concern or maybe they aren't and I'm not
just hedging about here I'll explain the
point behind this so the first is when
we think about retention rates this
conversation started at really when the
MOOCs took off and it started in some
ways with a flawed argument and the idea
was retention rates are five percent
because 150,000 people signed up for all
these courses and only you know I'm not
a mathematician so let's just say 55
thousand completed the course okay well
one of the problems with that argument
is that it was the denominator it was
based on this idea that the number of
students who enrolled for free in the
course we're all intending to complete
the course so the first thing we have
found out is that that is not true what
we see on average for our courses is
about fifty percent of the students who
enroll in a course ever actually go back
to the course once it starts
so you could say now I enroll in of
course two months ago then when the
course starts I never go into the class
I never engage with one learning
material in that course so if you think
about retention rates I don't think you
can base it on that idea of how many
students enrolled at how many students
finished so we need to think about what
we're talking about with retention rates
but more importantly the question is is
that even what we're after for MOOCs are
we after retention rates or are we after
engagement know if a student joins a
MOOC and only has the intention of
watching four weeks of lectures because
those are the only four topics that
they're interested in they watch the
four lectures and they leave I mean to
me that's not considered a failure and I
don't think we should consider that a
failure we have delivered a piece of
education that this student was after
and to me that's a successful metric so
once the courses are done we need to
really think about what we're trying to
measure and then how do we define the
measurements around this most of our
audience is international and educated
it will be no surprise that a kiehl's
constitutional law course is has the
largest number of us students he's at
forty-two percent domestic students
Bob's is on the other side of the
spectrum he's at eighteen percent
domestic and then Paul's and Diana's
ball very close to the average of twenty
seven percent on average less than ten
percent of the students enrolling in our
courses on Coursera don't have a
tertiary degree of some point all the
others have whether it's a bachelor's
and master's a PhD or some type of
professional degree there's I mean there
are so much exciting about our courses
on Coursera the one war that I would use
to describe our experience so far is
fascinating the data that we can get the
information how we how we've learned how
we teach students and how we share
information has just been incredible and
there are so many things I think
opportunities that we haven't even
thought of yet and here's one example
that sort of came our way late in the
game before we started the first round
of courses Diana kleiner created an
e-book that's a companion to her course
on Coursera as well as open your courses
and iTunes so she took some of her
images that are in the course and some
that she didn't publish in the course
and she created a ridge
250 word captions for each image and
allow the students worked with the yale
university press to dream up this new
digital asset this new digital learning
material that we hadn't thought about
when we first approached diana in april
to teach a course and i think this is an
example that there will be a lot of
opportunities that we haven't even begun
to imagine yet like any good list we
have a bonus and that is that although
these courses are distinctly yell if you
are watching one of these courses you
will know that this is a Yale course the
faculty member the subject the way we
cover it the way the broadcast and media
team has created the assets we shouldn't
confuse these with teaching a course in
New Haven to Yale students and we just
have to adjust our expectations and
adjust the way we think about them
because they are two different things
but we can learn a lot from each that
will help the other so I expect that
some of the learning that we do in the
in the MOOCs will help us as we think
about teaching students here in New
Haven and vice versa so those are our
top 11 i'm sure we'll develop more we
may even edit these as we go along these
are early ones any questions none okay
oh yeah Sarah great yeah can you say
something about who signed up for twit
and was on signature track versus open
and how that played into retention rates
well the retention rates for signature
track enrollees is multiples higher I
think the number is around seventy-five
percent at this point so nuts around we
expected around between seventy and
eighty percent signature versus not
signature track has I would say a few
thousand i can get the latest numbers
for you and share them yes
oh sorry as I know you're involved also
in the small online courses that were
offering a genomic som and I guess it's
pretty similar to what they are doing
with the summer cousins do you think
this Coursera courses are gonna affect
the way we teach in our other courses
that are for credit that professors
might become more facilitators and
students might get more protagonism
compared to these courses or you said we
should differentiate having a course
here and consider how is that different
or how will that affect the way
professors teaching class right so i
can't speak for how faculty will adapt
you know what they learned in MOOCs are
rather than of these will play a larger
role but i do think it provides us a
great opportunity to experiment with
online education in a way that's you
know different from a traditional yale
college classroom and the fact that we
have these tens of thousands of students
and some really interesting technology
tools at our disposal to think about how
do we structure conversations online to
students who are global who again are
from different demographic backgrounds
so i think it's a it's a great
experimentation for us and then it will
be interesting to see how individual
faculty members apply that learning to
their courses here in new haven right oh
absolutely so this was Jim Rolf from the
last session that we did where Jim had
this idea where when you look at the
MOOC model of watching lectures before
class or watching lectures and then
being assessed frequently on what you're
learning on those lectures Jim wanted to
take that model but put it in his
classroom Jim Ralph is a lecturer in
calculus and Yale College so when he and
I met last summer we were talking about
what it is he wanted to do needed to
create videos and he needed a system for
delivering those videos so I said to him
if we separate these two ideas creating
videos we can certainly do and guy or
oliva who's back on camera here worked
with Jim and is teaching fellow mac
Roseman to produce those videos that's
easy i said for the delivery we actually
do have a tool on campus available to is
that can do
it but we've never used it before and
this was last fall and that's Coursera
so we can deliver it and we can do the
assessment in video and then you can
work with the Coursera team to look at
the data to understand what your
students had more difficulty what
grasping and then tailor your
instruction in the classroom to those
topics that's exactly what he did and as
he said last time in the last session
the students who were in the section
where he delivered the video through
Coursera and then tailored the
instruction I think it was they their
performance on the midterm and final was
five percent higher on average than the
other student so that's an example where
you look at what this is teaching us
about teaching in some sense said you
have short video frequent assessment i
don't know that these concepts are new
but now we now have tools to make them
easier to translate into a yale college
classroom or Yale graduate and
professional classroom that's it
anything else well I think you can all
sense it this is an enormous project the
numbers involved all of the assessment
that's involved the organization of it
the filming of it with guy in the back
and a whole cadre of people I Ryan and
Sarah who are with us today as well and
it's a huge credit to Lukas to have
pulled all of this off and delivered in
a timely fashion and it's really quite
magnificent now we're about to stop here
and go home so I asked you are you going
to go home and watch the sixteenth
episode of house of cards or are you
going to tune in to Robert Shiller week
too it's a real tough decision I'll
leave that up to you so thanks for
joining us today and see you next time
you